hello everyone we got four different
news stories this week that i feel very
positively about uh concerning the
precedent that they set or the impact
they may have on the games industry
going forward and not enough good news
not enough good gaming news on youtube
so i thought that i would dive into the
four stories um the first being
minecraft and nfts this one's pretty cut
and dry and simple but just
i would love to praise them for their
approach to this
because
it proves that you can just you can just
do this you can just do what minecraft
has done here it's that easy otherwise
we're going to talk about the uk
government um approaching loot boxes
some game games industry unionization
stuff and some stock market stuff too
that again all of it i feel really
positively about which is nice because
i don't know maybe i'm getting to like
the old man yells at cloud age of video
games or i've been playing them for 20
plus years and i'm like back in my day
they look better but i still feel like
loot boxes and nfts suck so here we are
so this first one like i said this one's
pretty simple minecraft one of the
biggest games in the world
uh one of the biggest games to ever
exist
the highest selling game of all time
posted this on minecraft. that says
minecraft and nfts which at first is
like
so many industries went right for nfts
so many dev studios and publishers went
for nfts some of them made
money some of them made absolutely none
um but this is mojang's early look at
upcoming guidelines it says hello
everyone recently we've received some
feedback from members of community
asking for clarification and
transparency regarding mojang or moyang
i think it's actually pronounced studios
and minecraft's position on nft's
non-fungible tokens and blockchain while
we are in the process of updating our
minecraft usage guidelines to offer more
precise guidance on new technologies we
wanted to take the opportunity to share
our view that integrations of nfts with
minecraft are generally not something we
support or allow let's have a closer
look they've already nailed it but i
think what gets better about this is
that they explain why they're garbage
for the community
it's so wonderful
what is an nft an nft is a unique
non-editable digital token that is part
of a blockchain and often purchased with
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin an nft can
be associated with any form of digital
assets such as mpeg or a gif but the
most common use today is digital art
like jpegs the purchase of an nft
provides the token that states the
ownership of the original digital file
yet with any digital file that file can
be copied moved or even deleted nfts and
blockchain have also been associated
with speculation where prices are driven
up rapidly and as we have seen recently
recently seen may fall rapidly and the
craziest thing about um
speculation as they call it here
is there's evidence there's direct
evidence that
sellers have inflated the prices of
their own items and then
rug pulled it's just it's such garbage
uh how does this affect me
if you're a player or creator actively
involved in the buying selling or
trading of nfts that you make use of
minecraft like skins or worlds we
strongly suggest you go through the
information below otherwise it's likely
these changes won't affect you our
policies on nfcs and minecraft in our
minecraft usage guidelines we outline
how a server owner can change for access
i probably don't need to go over all of
this
but this is the thing that i think is
the best talking point that i think is
so hard for the pro nft community
to refute
nfts create models of scarcity and
exclusion that conflict without
guidelines and the spirit of minecraft
this is a fact like majority of games if
they if they pretend to be community
friendly have to also acknowledge that
nfts
create
an environment of false scarcity
and exclusion that is what they do by
default they also just change the reason
that people will play games they they
are rejecting the core of the video game
itself and making it about profiteering
which
if they ever tell you it's about the
community you're being goddamn like
uh
to ensure minecraft players have a safe
and inclusive experience blockchain
technologies are not permitted to be
integrated inside our client and server
applications nor may minecraft in-game
content such as world skins persona
items or other mods be utilized by
blockchain technology to create a scarce
digital asset our reasons follow this is
where it gets
so good i love this so much
some companies have recently launched
nft implementations that are associated
with minecraft world filers and skin
packs other examples of how nft's
blockchain can be utilized with
minecraft include creating minecraft
collectible nfts allowing players to
earn nfts through activities performed
on a server or earning minecraft nft
rewards for activities outside of the
game
uh they talk about creating digital
ownership based on scarcity and
exclusion which does not align with
minecraft values of creative inclusion
and playing together
again
most games have those values those are
the
values which with
most games from a design perspective
have to operate
it has to be about inclusivity and
playing together that is how they have
to function
nfts are not inclusive of all our
community and create a scenario of the
haves and have-nots and it's one that
that
blows um
because it's actually just halves that
have nots in terms of money it's not
habs and have nots in terms of skill
like again back in my day players used
to get cool skins because they were
really good players and so you'd see
them with like a cool helmet and you'd
be like damn that dude must have done
this or hit this level to be able to get
that he's cool but he had to work for
that it wasn't something that he bought
it's it's halves and have-nots in terms
of real-world money not even in-game
effort it's just the lamest thing ever
the speculative pricing and investment
mentality around nfts takes the focus
away from playing the game and
encourages profiteering which we think
is inconsistent with the long-term joy
and success of our players this
is the most beautiful sentence i have
seen any video game company write about
nfts
the speculative pricing and investment
mentality around nfts takes the focus
away from playing the game and
encourages profiteering that's why i
feel like a lot of the pro nft bros on
twitter who scream about how great nft
is off for video games and how like why
wouldn't you want to make bloody
complete game i don't think any of them
are gamers
if there's ever going to be an instance
where i'm going to keep video games and
tell you you're not a real gamer it's if
you like nfts you're not a real gamer
it's the only time i will ever say that
otherwise i'm like hey you only play
candy crush you're a gamer call yourself
a gamer i don't care
if you want nfts in video games you're
not a gamer that's where i draw the line
gate kept you are not a gamer you are
somebody who is trying to scam other
people you are interested in
profiteering and would be in any
industry you do not care about playing
the game you do not care about the
community of the game you care about
profiteering it's such a good sentence
i'm just so happy with minecraft for
doing this
uh we're also concerned that some
third-party nfts may not be reliable and
may end up costing players who buy them
which of course has happened effectively
repeatedly some third-party nft
implementations are also entirely
dependent on blockchain technology and
may require an asset manager who might
disappear without notice again has
happened repeatedly
there have also been instances where
nfts were sold at artificially or
fraudulent fraudulently inflated prices
you recognize that creation inside our
game has intrinsic value and we strive
to provide a marketplace where those
values could be recognized as such to
ensure that minecraft players have a
safe and exclusive experience sorry
inclusive literal opposite word
blockchain technologies are not
permitted to be integrated inside our
minecraft client and server applications
nor may they be utilized to create nfts
associated with any in-game content
including world skin persona items and
other mods
class act minecraft
this is beautiful
i hope that other studios who are trying
to pull this [ __ ]
that do it and then just like cancel out
because they
realize that it's not making them any
money it's not because they realize the
community doesn't like them by the way i
see so many people speculating about
that on twitter like why do people keep
doing it if they know the communities
could be bad they don't care they don't
care they've either been tricked into
thinking that nfts are great which i
think that like some of the people who
talk about them could certainly swindle
certain individuals into thinking that
it is the future but web 3 but
blockchain
some of those people have made a lot of
money for for them nfts have been great
for the most part they just don't care
they care about making money they don't
care about you being mad
they don't care simple as that
okay very happy about this story huge
win for minecraft you love to see it uh
the next one that i wanted to talk about
here
is this is from polygon and the article
says how qa workers are driving the
video game industry's union push um
which is certainly good news for a whole
lot of people underpaid undervalued qa
workers at activision blizzard and
keyword studios are pushing for more
equitable industry
let me
cut out the ads with my face
for decades the north american video
game industry has resisted unionization
though workers have long been organizing
among themselves the industry's first
official union didn't form until late
last year the movement is still young
with three industry unions on the books
and others in the works one group of
workers is consistently leading the
charge quality assurance
so if you didn't already know this which
a lot of people probably do but a lot of
people get their start in qa
a lot of people looking to get into game
development get their start in qa
and i've heard stories of particular
companies i believe this one was an ea
where they had a leaderboard for who
worked the most hours
that's
that's how you're being treated at your
entry level job
is a literal leaderboard for everybody
to see showcasing how many hours you
worked which are largely unpaid for the
record um people [ __ ] fall apart what
a horrendous thing for an industry
that's so beloved to do to people and
and that makes so much goddamn money
it's
terrible
and it's such an important part of it
too like if if a game comes out with
bugs players are gonna notice and for
the record throughout the development
cycle games can have like 50 000 bugs at
a certain point that's not even uncommon
but slowly get worked down meticulously
with a lot of skill it's not something
that is easy to do there are people who
are so skilled at qa who is so
talented and just have this like wealth
of knowledge that just doesn't apply to
your average player frankly your average
player submitting a bug report
they usually can't even be used because
they don't give enough detail of the
exact circumstances of how they found
the bug or the circumstances was
something that occurred three hours ago
and to the player they were like oh well
i got a little game crashed so you can't
replicate that it's like it's so much
more involved than i think people
realize and yeah they just get treated
like ass
uh quality assurance or simply book qa
works long hours to play test and break
games so that players at home never see
the hundreds or thousands of bugs that
can infest games during their
development
big games like call of duty can have
more than a thousand people trying to
squash bugs often under serious crunch
conditions
qa workers across the industry often
describe their work as undervalued with
low wages and brutal overtime hours
many work on a contract basis meaning
they have little job security and face
challenges in advancing their careers qa
workers say they feel vulnerable and
exploited the video game industry topped
60.4 billion in revenue in 2021 yet some
qa workers tell polygon they can't
afford to commute to the office that's
what i'm talking about it's such an
important part of a game
launching a buggy game or launching a
game without a qa team you couldn't the
game wouldn't exist
and yet
they're just they're really just treated
like lab rats it's it's terrible
so despite this lots of qa workers are
passionate about their jobs and want to
progress in the industry and that's why
they're trying to change it which i
wholly support
the first video game union wasn't purely
qa or contract workers though i do think
contract workers have a hard run of it
too that is definitely a problem uh that
was beast breaker developer video games
historic union win in 2021 which
encompassed the whole studio activision
blizzard qa workers at raven software
kicked off their union drive next which
is like
huge yeah it says here first breaking
ground at a big corporate video game
company so cool to see
after a long back and forth with
activision blizzard the group calling
themselves game workers alliance won
their union vote dragon age 4 qa workers
at keyword studios organized next
solidifying their union with the alberta
labour board in june now a third group
of qa workers again with activision
blizzard are making a union push under
blizzard albany the studio formerly
known as vicarious visions that worked
on activision's tony hawk pro skater
games
it's weird to see
vicarious visions listed as pro skater
at this point because i so strongly
associate them with crash bandicoot now
that the association is so strong i
don't know
uh it's a monumental time for the video
game industry built on years of
organizing that came before it and like
in other industries it's largely been
the most vulnerable workers taking the
lead which again
awesome the fact that this is succeeding
at all is unexpected um it's super
exciting there is a fly in this room
please uh ignore that
um goes on to say it's part of the
larger labor movement that's happening
keyword studios qa worker james russ
worm told polygon we have the starbucks
workers who are taking the united states
by its storm and the same with amazon
workers because of the economic
pressures you're really seeing the
workers who are least paid a hit the
hardest it's like we're trying to find
all the bugs in the labor and make sure
we get some fixed which is a very
wonderful
analogy
i'll leave a link to this article below
if you want more of the details um but
yeah it does go on to give some more
details about
unions in general and people taking
advantage of qa which is definitely um
a correct thing but i just really wanted
to highlight how excited i am by people
getting
more
invested in unions i think part of the
problem beforehand was that people
always felt like the industry wouldn't
take them seriously like the unions
would be rejected and when you feel that
way which is like effectively propaganda
they want you to feel that way so that
you won't start a union then you won't
start a union the fact that more and
more studios are doing this it's just
such a positive going forward i would
love to see the industry end up the
games industry end up with something
akin to sag my only fear is that the
industry cares so much about profits
that that would result in more
monetization in video games more
egregious monetization and video games
to offset that cost but
people need to get treated better
it's awesome i support the unions
good job everybody involved you're
killing it keep going uh okay the next
one more good news look at us go
the uk government says the games
industry must act on loot boxes or face
legislation now this has happened across
like a number of different countries
a number of times
crop that
just sometimes when i wear a dress on
youtube it makes me look like i don't
have clothes on and
that's uh unfortunate okay
uk government says the games industry
must act on loot boxes or face
legislation a working group will be
formed to develop industry-led measures
to protect players
the uk government has said the games
industry must do more to protect
vulnerable players from loot boxes and
that it will not hesitate to consider
legislation if companies do not bring in
sufficient measures to keep players safe
a 2020 call for evidence on loot boxes
launched by the uk's department for
digital culture media and sport found
that players who purchase loot boxes may
be more likely to experience gambling
mental health financial and problem
problem gaming related harms
the risk may also be higher for children
and young people it was found which i've
told this story a number of times but in
case you haven't heard it
i when i was very young
i was playing a game called habbo hotel
which is still around
and uh all you had to do to spend money
and have a hotel which it like it let
you buy a cool house or like put it let
you decorate a space effectively um
there was a shop where you could buy
like a digital couch and that's what i
was doing it for
all i had to do was make a phone call
and then put in a code
and i was young enough that i had no
concept of of that being real money but
it charged my parents phone bill so it
like charged our landline at home and my
parents had to be like what is this who
did this and i guess it like they saw
that it was related to gaming when they
called the company and so obviously came
to me
um
but i
feel like reflecting on that experience
now it was intentionally that easy for
me as a child to pick up a phone and
make that phone call and make that money
obviously they made things slightly more
difficult now but i feel like there's
still a lot of work to do and loot boxes
in general
it is gambling why is it not being
regulated by gambling
like gambling sorry um on sunday the
government called for the purchase of
loot boxes to be made unavailable to
children and young people which i'm
fully in support of unless they are
approved by a parent or guardian and we
have to actually approve them by a
parent or guardian not just let the kid
type in a passcode and assume that that
means it's been approved
it has to they have to be better
barriers than that we want to stop
children going on spending sprees online
without parental consent which is
exactly what i did
spurred on by in-game purchases like
loot boxes said culture secretary
cultures culture culture secretary
nadine doris in a statement
game companies and platforms need to do
more to ensure that controls and age
restrictions are applied so the players
are protected from the risk of gambling
harms
sorry
children should be free to enjoy gaming
safely whilst giving parents and
guardians the peace of mind they need
while dory's highlighted that she
expects companies to do more to ensure
children can't make purchases without
parental consent no formal action has
been taken to tighten restrictions
around digital purchases hopefully
that's just a
yet
the department for digital culture media
and sports said it plans to form a
working group comprised of game
companies platforms and regulatory
bodies in order to develop what it calls
industry-led measures to protect players
and reduce the risk of harm
so it doesn't seem like this is like
anything that's necessarily actionable
yet
but
they're working on it it is continuing
to make headlines
uh this is a reference to last year oh
my god it's 20 22 years ago in july 2020
following repeated calls for action from
the government
the house of lords recommended the uk
government act immediately to bring loot
boxes within the remit of gambling
legislation legislation and regulation i
just so strongly agree a number of
countries have done this
it mentions the belgian gaming
commission which is probably the most
famous one uh which found that loot
boxes such as those sold for real
currency and fifa's ultimate team
constituted gambling which
of course they do
of course they do who are we kidding
they 100 are gambling that's that's just
what it is you are
throwing money in the hopes of getting
something and what you're purchasing
isn't real anyway like it's
it's so brutal um so as a result of that
games either have their loot boxes
removed in belgium or aren't sold there
at all ea for example announced in 2019
that it would no longer sell fifa points
in belgium
uh last month 20 consumer groups from 18
european countries launched a
coordinated action asking authorities to
pass regulations on loot boxes you'd
love to see it i want to see more of it
keep going great news everybody great
games industry news
the last one
is
oh my god everybody got pop-ups
people always like why don't you use an
ad blocker to be fair i'm trying to
support these websites
still sometimes it's a bit egregious
okay so we're on pc gaming now
uh cd project stock is worth a quarter
of what it was before cyberpunk 2077 was
released and
this is obviously terrible news for cdpr
this is very good news for the industry
as a whole
hear me out i know that the gaming
audience often feels like they hate
delays they get very upset about delays
it's like they feel like game developers
are incompetent which is really not how
it works
this happening
means that when a publisher goes to a
game studio and says we want this out in
this quarter
there is actually something tangible to
point to for one of the first times ever
where a studio head or director can say
no
we are not ready to release the game yet
stocks will tank it will actually affect
the company because we know that the
publishers don't necessarily care about
the public backlash which certainly
seems like it was the case
for cdpr it's i've seen so many devs at
that studio and i've spoken to people
personally who were like we knew it
wasn't ready but they wouldn't listen to
us we needed more time
um and they should have been given more
time
but the
outcome of that obviously very negative
thing happening for that studio is that
hopefully now there is a thing that can
be pointed to to say look it actually
mattered because they don't care
about community backlash
obviously the game still reviewed very
well it got eights and nines and i think
that's because it still played
relatively well i mean it did play well
on pc i had a great time playing it on
pc outlaunch but
it it wasn't affected by the community
in any way whatsoever and again i don't
think these companies actually care
about the community as much as anyone
thinks they do they don't care they care
about money the game still sold very
well cyberpunk sold well there was no
impact on it even including the refunds
it still made a lot of money there was
no [ __ ] impact but there are a lot of
cases where sales aren't even as
important as stocks or shares are to
publicly traded companies in the games
industry so there was no lesson that
gamers gave them there was no lesson at
all the the game sold well
even if people yelled about it it had no
impact on them it's still got good
reviews there's still loads of uh
content surrounding the game like people
are talking about it constantly like
gamers didn't do anything
to say hey we don't want this other than
a yell into a void that has no actual
impact in my opinion
uh the stocks
matter the stocks matter a lot
um so a new report from business insider
poland paints a grim picture for cd
projekt which you know i don't want i i
hope that cdpr recover from this the
company's value has create created by
over 75
since just before the launch of
cyberpunk 2077. a business has once
boasted a market capitalization of over
40 billion polish
polish
money briefly becoming the most valuable
games company in europe is now worth
less than 10 billion
polish monies
anyways leading up to cyberpunk's launch
cdpr shares cdp sorry um
trading at around 400 each hitting 443 a
share only six days before the game's
release the story since then has been
one of sharp balls and brief plateaus
with cdpr shares and market cap halving
in value in the first few months of 2021
then almost halving again since the end
of march this year um
so the reception of cyberpunk is the
conclusion that pc gamer is drawn and
subsequent firefighting of the problems
has shown off five years of the
company's overall value
nuts this is despite cyberpunk 2077
selling almost 14 million copies in 2020
alone like i said the game did sell
really well
ever since launch the developer has been
largely focused on fixing problems with
the game mainly on console it has to be
said and multiplayer mode that was once
promised is now not happening perhaps
the most humiliating moment perception
wise was that sony removed the game from
the playstation store it has
subsequently returned so this is
obviously a part of this
it's not just that
the game launched poorly that
frankly it's actually probably not that
the game launch poly on console that was
the issue for the stock market
actually at all that probably wasn't
what mattered it said that they've had
to spend so much time fixing it that
they are now not producing other things
that would make more money um cdpr are
not a valuable
publicly traded company right now
because they aren't working on anything
that a shareholder can look at in six
months and go oh that's gonna pay off i
should buy this now because all they're
doing is bug fixing [ __ ] that people
have already bought because they
released a game that uh didn't even
function in some cases from what i've
seen
um the company's post cyberpunk plummet
has left its market cap trending around
a level equivalent to its value in 2017.
it's probably to be expected that a game
company's value would drop a bit after
their much hype game finally released
the dizzying scale of cdp's fall can
hardly be interpreted as anything but a
result of cyberpunk's mismanagement
which does seem to be the issue is
mismanagement perhaps more going for cdp
is the possibility that they are no
longer poland's biggest game studio
business insider poland draws on some
maths done by paul's business who a
polish business daily to suggest that
techland might now be poland's biggest
game company by market cap yeah dying
light 2 did really well right um the
numbers on this one are pretty fuzzy
though tecline aren't listed on a stock
exchange so they had to guess as to what
their share price would be
um
that is a bit hairy i also don't feel
like that necessarily matters that much
to the rest of us but
it's not the end of the world for cdp
which i strongly agree with i think
they'll bounce back just fine when
they're actually
working on things that can make money uh
whereas right now really just bug fixing
which thankful for
but uh obviously not appealing to the
stock market in 2017 cdp was still in
the optical of the witcher 3's release
and had only released its last dlc a
year prior returning to a 2017 era
market cap then doesn't mean cdp is on
the vote of shutting up shop but it does
show
that what's happened with cyberpunk has
hurt the studio no wonder that all of a
sudden it's talking about a new witcher
game
um
again i feel largely very positively
about this because i do think that it
means that creatives can tell executives
hey it actually [ __ ] matters sales
didn't matter community didn't matter
the stock market really does matter
people really care about the stock
market
i'm hoping that that is the outcome uh
it's also just a matter of how the
company responds like cdpr
has obviously chosen to take that hit
they have chosen not to continue not to
drop cyberpunk and to just work on other
stuff that could make more money two
years later they could have done that
and didn't so they have almost opted
into that hit there isn't a guarantee
that every company would do that there
are loads of companies
i feel like battlefield's a very good
example that they release a game and do
not funnel all of their resources into
fixing it if it came out broken they
just kind of let it happen and then keep
making [ __ ] that we'll make more money
so that the stock market hit doesn't
occur so cd projekt has has again opted
into this happening effectively by
focusing on those bug fixes which props
um
but i still
really hope this sends a message
that you shouldn't [ __ ] release games
until they're ready
just wait please just wait
good news across the board thank you all
for joining me for this
26 unedited minutes
about game news this week i'm gonna try
and do more game news videos especially
for stuff i feel positively about like i
said too many people on youtube just
yelling about stuff that makes him mad
and i feel very very good about all
these stories this minecraft post is
like one of the best things i've ever
seen anyone in the industry post it's so
good